earlier today mark ronson revealed he
identifies a sapiosexual which means
he's attracted to intelligence before
physical appearance or gender before he
appeared on Good Morning Britain the
hosts actually got into a heated debate
on the topic due to the French equality
minister saying she identifies as
sapiosexual but British journalist Nicky
Hodgson explained what it means
so the definition of sapiosexual 'ti
doesn't mean not physical attraction it
means intelligence first so that's how I
identify intelligence for me is the most
important attractive trait in a person
and I've dated men women trans men trans
women across the gender spectrum
identifying I was bisexual and the thing
that has linked all these people that I
have dated have been their brains the
award winning producer couldn't help but
overhear the discussion while waiting
backstage and revealed to producers the
heat also identifies a sapiosexual but
you just didn't know there was a term
for it although the purpose of his
appearance on the show was to discuss
his latest album late-night feelings
Ronson decided to get involved in the
conversation and now that we know that
you're single he's got very involved
mark in our safety sexually and you're
identifying as a man who likes intellect
I did I didn't know that there was a
word for it but okay yeah I was really
enjoying that segment we're all arguing
back in the dressing room yes a couple
of your producers and yes I feel like
I'm identified sapiosexual the hosts
applauded Ronson for being out and proud
and they added it was great news
considering his divorce in 2018 which
inspired his recent album which explores
many shades of heartbreak including his
collaboration with Miley Cyrus
[Music]
his list of collaborations on the album
include camilla Kibeho
and king princess and of course marcus
spent years working alongside lady gaga
who has always been one of the biggest
supporters of individuality and has been
constantly a voice for the queer
community so what do you think of mark
revealing he's sapiosexual has mark
saying he identifies as sapiosexual made
you aware of the term what do you most
value in a partner let us know in the
comments below and don't forget to
subscribe to ET Canada's YouTube page
[Music]
you